all right hello everybody welcome
to games of the week so for this stream
i'm going to cover i'm going to cover a
few of my games
from this week's title tuesday
so these are blitz games from chess.com
so we're going to see there's some
there's a lot of tactics some oversights
that we'll talk about some will gloss
over
but this title tuesday i got to play a
few very strong players
had some good games and so we're just
going to talk through those stages
kind of how a gm approaches these
positions some important factors
all right let's get into it so this
first game
was against vladimir putin
big fish on chess.com and he'd actually
already handed me a couple losses in
previous title tuesdays
he's a very strong player he's rated
about 3100
so that made this game right a bit of a
revenge
but if i hope for revenge you might say
so he plays e4 c5 knight f3 knight c6
so pretty standard sicilian and these
days
actually does anyone know right for a
long time d4 is of course very standard
in the sicilian
it's used to be played i would say
basically all the time it's played in
most sicilians
but nowadays there's a very major
alternative here
does anyone know what is it was actually
played quite a bit by caruana against
carlson the world championship match
does anyone know what the major
alternative is for white here
what the line is and what it's called
yeah so i'm steven zurp that's the name
said on chess.com and only chess i am z
kid
right so nowadays and actually i tend to
see this more than d4 now
bishop b5 the rossolimo very common
because after d4
after d4 right takes takes there's a few
things black can do
well i can do e5 which is the
kalashnikov black could do knight f6
knight c3 here e5 is the sveshnikov d6
is the classical
and actually if i even forgot to mention
here black can also play g6 into an
accelerated dragon
all strong openings you know especially
this vishnakov is a favorite of carlson
those are all very playable so the point
is after d4 there's a lot black can do
and by no means is any of it easy easy
to deal with
there's a lot of difficult work there
for white
so nowadays i mean after bishop b5 black
has a lot of choice
you know the move i played g6 is very
popular but you can also play e6 and d6
as main moves
knight f6 even queen c7 or queen b sex
can be played here
a lot of choices
that being said although black can do a
lot of things the play takes
on a much more strategic tone there's
not a lot of sharp lines like there are
in some of those
other open sicilians after d4
so i'd say you reach a more strategic
name generally in these positions
so yeah and as some couple of you
mentioned like can also play the delayed
alpine here with c3
which is perfectly doable
so in this game he plays bishop b5 into
the rossolimo
my response is g6
and as i mentioned there's several other
valid ideas you can you can play e6
intending knight e7
or d6 intending bishop sorry bishop d7
just aiming to fianchetto the bishop
and for a long time for a while and what
karwana played against carlson is he
just took the knight
and black can take back either way both
lead to extremely interesting games
if b takes c6 is a little sharper d
takes c6 is more strategic
but nowadays a lot of people too are
avoiding this capture
and sure enough white castle bishop g7
so white's preserving the possibility
right white can still take on c6 if they
want
but at the same time maybe why it leaves
it for a while
black doesn't want to spend a move on
something like a6 to induce the capture
because that would be
they would be a big loss in development
but maybe if circumstances are right
white will take on c6 later
and white's just preserving the option
there's a couple other moves here
so one of them is rookie one
this is another very popular move here
black can respond with e5
when actually it's
it starts to take on an appearance of
some e45 openings actually with the
fianco
like the kosio and black can go knight
e7
and this is perfectly playable for white
but you're kind of asking what exactly
is the rook doing here right e4 is not
pressured there's not much going on on
the e file
so e5 blocks the bishop but it's a very
good response to ricky one
and of course black has a very strong
grip on d4
so white plays a little differently
white plays a logical move i would say
why play
c3 and this is another move that's
especially popular now
caruana won a great game against dupont
in it that might be material for a
future lecture
and so first of all i would say this
move
committing to c3 this is very
has one big upside and one significant
downside
so after e5 from black what is the
future of the bishop on g7
so generally speaking
you're right that in the short term it's
not a monster right because this
diagonal is blocked
but it's compensated well by black's
very strong central control and easy
development
it also means that since e5 is played
white's d-pawn another point to note is
white's d-pawn is still back here
if this pawn we're on d5 i'd say it's
very bad but
any time white wants to play d4 this
bishop will spring
to life the position will open up in a
way that black is happy to see
and if white doesn't play d4 white's
just not putting that much pressure on
black
right then black has a come as a
comfortable amount of space
and a very very solid position
so it's just it's not that the bishop on
g7 is doing a ton right now
but it has a lot of potential right
white never wants to mess with this e5
pawn but if he doesn't do these breaks
if white doesn't do one of these breaks
then it's a lot harder for white to do
anything
not that it's impossible this is of
course doable but you can see it has
some advantages for black as well
instead c3
so c3 has some good control in the
center it's true
and yeah if black plays e5 now if black
plays e5 after c3 instead
now d4 is much stronger right we haven't
played this random rookie one here
rookie 1 would look silly
but suddenly c3 is a very good move now
before black can develop
white just charges into the center with
d4
and black can and should take this
but this while it's playable
it's very dangerous for black compared
to the rookie one line black has to be
very careful here
and maybe black can manage but treading
on thin ice
so c3 is preparing well for t4
but as the downside though yep as
mentioned correctly it inhibits the
knight
right white hasn't defended the e4 pawn
white can't play knight c3 anymore
and black basically seizes the moment by
playing knight f6
so before white can play d4 and claim
this huge center
black asks okay so what are you doing
about your e4 pawn then now that you've
taken away the c3 square
and white can't just give away this pawn
so typically white will play rook u1
because white still wants to play d4 of
course right that's the point of c3
but we've gotten so we've gotten this
handy development and white's b1 knight
is a little sad
and after rookie one black castles white
plays d4
and now black plays d5 right away
this position is a little tricky but one
point of note
i want to make a lot of times when you
see pawns like this
and it can be the same situation if it's
white pawns on c4 and d5 versus a black
pawn and c6
when you have pawns like this very often
you don't want to make this trade
because you're getting rid of the c
pawns and the only thing you're
achieving is you're giving white snipe
this c3 square
right white denied himself this square
with the c3 move
but now now he gets it back so generally
speaking that exchange is favorable to
white
yes black black is me so this is my game
against
fedocer from title tuesday
that's right we don't we want to leave
this pawn on c3 to get in the way
and d5 right so
white's taking a claim in the center
we're staking our own
e5 this is all very typical
and the knight jumps into e4
so now now that white's played these
moves
right this is a big commitment from
white
and it's it's a it's a good line and
once again though let's try to
understand it
what are the i guess what are the
upsides and downsides
of advancing the pawns like this and you
don't just see this here right you see
something similar in the french
in the advanced caro con in other
variations
these pawns have a very strong
restricting effect
especially on this bishop like funnily
enough we talked about the bishop being
hindered if black plays e5 but it's
actually these pawns
are doing even more right it can't even
go to f6
on the flip side yeah on the flip side
that means
these squares are a little less well
defended because the pawns have moved
past them
and once the pawns have moved past
squares they can't you know they can't
go back and defend them
that's one of the key points it's
actually one of
the most difficult parts of chess is
understanding when your pawns can safely
advance
and right we can try to destroy it so
this is key and if you play the french
you know this well
when white advances their pawns like
this you very often want to strike with
your own pawns like this
you know that's that's honestly the
french in a nutshell is
the battle between these pawns in a lot
of lines
and this position turns out to be very
similar
so now white takes on c6
it's not the only move but it does it
does reduce the pressure on d4
it's perfectly good and one thing white
wants to do
what eventually wants to control this c5
square
and make this pawn on c6 a weakness
and now bishop e3 is played
and as we can see white is heavily
prioritizing dark square control
right the light squares are a little
weakened which is good news for this
bishop
but at the same time ironically even
though by the traditional definition
with a lot of light squared pawns and a
lot of
for black and a lot of dark squared
pawns for white this would be the bad
yeah and so yes no if you have questions
don't be shy
yes so i want to play queen b6
but before i do i take on d4
takes takes and now queen b6 which
generally yes it's a move black wants to
make
you bring the queen out with tempo you
target this pawn
and c5 is a likely idea in the future
when black is ready for it
and here
here my opponent actually plays rookie
too to reinforce this pawn
so this move has some logic behind it
let me ask this
where do the rooks ultimately where do
white's rooks want to be in the long
term
in this pawn structure if white can
complete their development
and get their rooks wherever they want
where should the rooks go
because obviously e2 is not
e2 is not a permanent home for this rook
right on the c file yeah so this
is a very likely long-term plan for
black for white sorry
when c5 will never happen and this c
pawn will just be an unpleasant weakness
for a long time
and some ross limo games go this way
right black has to be careful
that white doesn't just get to do this
but in this case i do
i am keeping bishop a6 and and that's a
good suggestion
for the moment though i play f6
so i'm trying to break open these pawns
and incidentally rookie 2 has another
big downside i hadn't mentioned actually
one point is that this knight on f3
is very vulnerable to bishop g4 now
right it's
with the knight on f3 would be doubly
pinned to two major pieces
and so besides the threat of taking on
f3 and ruining white's pawn structure
e5 also becomes a lot weaker after
bishop g4
so i do believe that slightly better
would be queen c1
for the reason that it solves these pin
problems
it also supports knight c3 to recapture
with the queen
rookie 2 means that white has some
concerns about this move
all right you don't want to play it
right away because if you play it right
away after h3
takes takes suddenly you look up and say
oh wait my knight is trapped
so for concrete reasons we don't play it
yet but it's in the air it's something
white has to worry about f6
and in this position white kind of
realized the problems that could arise
if bishop g4 comes and white played
knight e1
so on the one hand strategically this is
logical
you're solving the pin problem
permanently you have this f3 idea now
and you're asking this night where it's
going
but on the other hand
on the other hand what's not so good
about this move what
why might white not want to play this
move right now
couple reasons but f6 knight d2
if you mean so this knight to d2 knight
fd2 and a bishop
bishop g4 f3 so that's true if knight d2
that also solves the problem of bishop
g4
on the other hand for one thing black
could do
queen takes b2 is in the air now so
after knight fd2 maybe bishop a6
to kick the rook back and then take on
b2 next
yeah the problem is knight fd2 like 91
actually
it weakens a lot of points right it
weakens b2 because it cuts off the
support
and it weakens e5 because it moves away
from that so knight ft2 does solve
the pin problem but it introduces some
other ones
so funnily enough i'd actually looked at
a very similar position before
with gm josh cordell actually so we
looked at this position and talked about
this f6 idea for black
and we actually talked about h3 to cover
this bishop g4 threat
and then it stops those threats but
black gets a lot of play in the center
with quick development
suffice to say it's very tricky for
white
but 91
what's the big downside of 91
i mean again it's preparing f3 i can
understand why maybe d3 is a good square
for the knight in the near future
right covering e5 and c5
but for just this moment right for this
move that knight is on a very passive
square
and white's development is not complete
not even close
white's pieces are a little clumsy not
defending things well these pieces
aren't out yet
so first i go bishop a6 forcing rook c2
and here now that the knight is back on
e1 or it's not doing much for the moment
actually as we're going to turn out it's
even a hindrance as it's going to turn
out
takes takes and here i played something
i'd seen in a very similar position
i played d4 which tactically is very
strong
but on the other hand it actually this
is actually a great example
of relying too much on patterns
because while d4 leads to a very good
position for black here
it creates some very strong threats as
it turns out there's a much stronger
move
can anyone find it a much simpler move
and i was so happy with d4
i forgot last year's maxim you see a
good move look for a better one
yeah d4 and the rook will come to d8 so
don't get me wrong that's very good for
black
it creates some very very dangerous
threats
can anyone spot the stronger move
knight well knight takes f2 takes with
the bishop
and the rook is providing support i
don't think you have quite enough
firepower to break through on f2
right yeah it's actually funnily enough
this could be a tactics puzzle just on
pretty much anywhere
queen takes e3
yep thanks to this knight on e1 f1 is
unguarded
and if white takes this rook f1
checkmate
so that was a big moment but
unfortunately right this is again why
you remember laxatives maxim
i've seen d4 work very well in similar
positions so i focused all my energy on
that
i didn't stop to think that there might
just be something right but there might
just be a quick win here but queen e3 is
a nice catch
but okay after d4
if bishop takes d4 you play rook d8
and this pin is crushing black just has
too many pieces
right if white takes the queen takes
bishop a5 and funnily enough i mean
white can't really even get out even if
black doesn't do anything
even if you just play bishop takes e5
all of white's pieces are tied down
and bishop d4 next should be crushing
right the biggest problem is of course
these pieces
they just can't they can't get out
simply but there is also bishop d3 right
trying to win this knight directly but i
really like bishop e5
so bishop takes d4 is out of the
question with this pin
black gets the rook to the crushing d1
square
so white goes queen d4
this is logical all right when you're
being attacked too
it's very logical to trade queens
now after takes takes there's no pin
so after rook 88 you don't have to worry
about the queen here
and white goes knight f3 in this
position i had had something in mind
it's a bit tricky white's got some good
defensive resources white is not far
from getting developed right if white
just plays knight c3 and consolidates
doing very very well
so black has to act quickly what might
black play here
to try and punish white's momentary
lack of development
we want to do something quick
so rook takes f3 it's tricky because
after g takes the knight is hanging
and if you take and white takes you've
got some play this actually does look
good for black
all right you can check and bishop d3
so this is pretty good don't get me
wrong this is good for black it's a move
worth looking at by all means
but there's something i would say more
forcing that is more clearly good for
black
rook takes f3 it's
the powerful pieces you get right the
rook and bishop when the rook gets to d1
are very strong but at the same time
this end game is still quite tricky
instance here
and after say takes year and takes
black is doing very well but we can win
more long story short
what might be a more direct way to try
and just win material here
think about what i mean black would love
to get this rook to d1 right
we talked about that before with the pin
even without the white queen on d1
it's still a square we'd really like to
use for a couple reasons right a pin
and a back rank made idea
right c5
yeah so pretty simple idea right we want
we want this d
file open for our rook so we target the
bishop
so white has a white is a tricky defense
here that had to be foreseen
but before we cover that let's cover a
couple other moves so first of all if
white takes the pawn right
it's just mate all right no h3 has been
played
that crank meet
now if white goes bishop c3
this is another nice tactic rook d1
directly
is very good for black
you can also do it this way
take here and takes
and this check and actually this knight
on e4 which keeps being targeted
suddenly after king g2 bishop f1
it does the crucial job of covering the
g3 square
white is forced to go back and we have
another back rank mate
so bishop c3 right trying to cover the
back rank through e1
does not work you can also do rook here
with a similar idea
right bishop b1 takes f3
so bishop c3 right white still needs
that one move
and they're not going to get it
so let's say all right let's say you're
playing white here
what's another try right you can't move
the bishop
bishop's targeted but what's one last
resource white has to try and
complete development without just giving
up a piece
couple more moves to this tactic
just because the bishops attack doesn't
mean that the bishop must be moved
anytime the threat is not checked right
checks have to be answered rules of
chess
but any other threat
any other threat you should always think
about can i ignore it
knight bd2 is the right idea but then
black takes
and takes the bishop and blacks up a
piece
right good catch knight c3
yeah knight c3 is white's trick
the idea is pretty simple this knight is
hanging now too in addition to the
bishop
the back ring threats are permanently
solved because now this rook is out
if you take the bishop white takes the
knight if you take the knight
white takes back with the bishop
and saves his peace while recapturing
yours
here though we have one last resource
for black
black to play all right if it weren't
for a tactic here white would actually
be doing pretty well
white seems to be consolidating their
development
so how does black win material here
right the counter counter tactic to
white's counter tactic
yeah it's a battle of the number of
tactical resources that is true
actually there's a very there's a great
game rashevsky fisher
where they do counter-tactic after
counter-tactic of each other something
like four form
four or five full moves of just counter
tactical resources like this
it's one of my favorite games perhaps
subject for a future lecture
right so c takes white gets his knight
back
but at the end of everything the end of
all these moves
bishop d3 is the final tactic
and black wins a piece
all right now there's no more tricks
left for white right all of black's
pieces are pretty solidly defended
in this position he actually put up
quite a bit of defense considering how
far behind white is now
it's a tough position to win but
but ultimately i'm not going to cover
that part too much in depth
in the end black converted his extra
piece
so this is the title tuesday game chess
king this is actually from
just a couple days ago
right yeah though i believe yeah the
scorpions sting at the end of the
combination
i believe that's a fisher quote right
it's a fisher quote referring to
i don't remember which combination ah
the fisher game
okay let me see so
now it was rushevsky fisher i'm blanking
on the year unfortunately but fischer
won with black
and it ends up in a very nice fisher has
rook and knight against two rooks and it
ends in a nice work in game
i will find that game later
unfortunately i apologize i am blanking
on the year
but it's one of their most famous games
if you look for their famous games
it's probably the first one you'll get
all right and that's the end of the
story for this game
so next up we're going to look at my
last game
yeah yes douglas yeah it's in my 60
memorable games
indeed that is where i first saw it i
believe you have both the fisher quote
and the rashinski fisher game
are in that book
so black converted the extra piece long
story short
the next game we're going to look at
yeah well both rashevsky fell for a fork
fisher fell for a fork
it's hard to say who really fell for
what because they both found a lot of
counter tactics
so this game was actually i was black
also from this title tuesday i was black
against parham marxus
the tournament gone well so this game
was actually kind of a decider
for a top three spot
and this game though actually was a very
instructive loss for me
it starts off with the english i was
playing black
i play e5 my standard move against it
g3 knight c6
all of this is pretty well known so this
is actually if you play c4 e5
a lot of the time it turns into a
reverse sicilian of sorts
right it's literally the same just with
opposite colors pushed
and so you can get actually just about
every sicilian variation
with white a tempo up on where black
normally is
you can get just about every variation
of the sicilian right i've played
in these kinds of positions i've played
the reverse night or for the reverse
classical the reverse dragon
the reverse shenanigan reverse time and
all of them
in this game though goes knight c3
bishop g7
e3 and black goes for a quick f5
actually out of curiosity can anyone
tell this is another reverse sicilian
pretty well-known version of a sicilian
what
if we reverse the colors right if this
were white set up
what kind of sicilian would this be
as a hint of sorts it's a sicilian where
d4 hasn't been played right black hasn't
played d5 and he's certainly not playing
it now
right it's like a reverse closed
sicilian exactly
right a closed sicilian where knight c3
knight c6 has been played
the bishop gets fianchettoed a grand
prix that would be possible too
but that's more that tends to be more if
this bishop is developed out here
you know like bishop b5
like bishop b5 for white so yeah this is
actually very much a closed sicilian
and as we're going to see it looks
exactly like the closed sicilian more
as the game goes on right very often
white plays f4 and puts the knight on f3
so this is actually a great example too
if we're
understanding of an opening you know not
just memorizing lines because the tempe
are different right
i'm down to tempo on where i usually is
so if you if you genuinely understand
if you understand the ideas
all right that can prove fruitful in
other cases too all right if you
understand the white side of the
sicilian
it gives you a lot of insight into the
black side of c4e5
so white castles i castle
and as a question in this kind of
position when from
in the closed sicilian in this setup
which normally it's black that has
does anyone know what is the typical
idea where does black typically play
does anyone know what what does white do
here i'll ask it that way
right so white pushes on the queen side
so in the closed sicilian
in the closed sicilian very often black
plays rook b8 and b5 b4
and similarly right so if you played
that you might recognize the same plan
from white white plays rook b1
aiming for this b4
and these this can actually work very
well with this bishop sometimes b7 can
be weak as we'll see in this game
and so ultimately it depends on exactly
what happens but similar to the closed
sicilian
black often plays g5 brings this knight
around
and black often goes for play on this
side of the board right where he's
already advanced
now sometimes white contests so we're
going to see all these ideas that are
very common in the closed sicilian
right black playing chief white playing
g4 and knight to g3
and then black playing f5 all of it
happens with colors reversed so it
really highlights the value i'd say
of really understanding openings
yeah good question so what about yeah
maybe maybe 97
and c6 d5
yeah this is so we're going to see this
is also an idea
and actually that is an idea like c3d4
that i should have paid more attention
to
so first of all i throw an a5 to stop b4
white plays a3
this is a pretty standard exchange in
this position it just means that
white still gets b4 but when he does we
trade and my rook gets the a file
and then after that after that exchange
i play d6
so now white goes b4 takes takes and 97
right keeping up the same plan i was
talking about
and now white goes b5
so again all very standard stuff
why don't you play e4
so yeah the problem is right every pawn
move creates weaknesses
so two things come to mind for me about
e4 you know it actually it doesn't look
like the least reasonable move i will
certainly say that
yeah the e4 move right it creates weak
squares on f4 and d4
if i were going to play it i played
before 97 so this knight could come here
but yeah so it creates these f4 and d4
squares
and when black plays e4
and again it's not no it's not a
terrible idea by any means there are
positions where you play it white can
also play d3 so white gets rid of this
advanced font you've created
and that means you've lost this strong
central influence that the pawn gives
you now
so those would be the reasons i'd give
but i don't play it
so in this position and in this position
actually i really like douglas's idea
right this b7 pawn is actually kind of
an annoying weakness
it seems like a simple thing right only
the bishop's attacking it
and only the bishop will attack it so it
seems simple to defend
but at the same time it's kind of
annoying that my bishop has to deal with
it
so here i actually really like the idea
of playing c6
both both have been played here before
but this means that the bishop can come
out safely this is well defended
i want to be a bit cautious about
playing d5 right away
because often for example this bishop
can come to this diagonal
and target me this way
but it's nice to have the option right
this pawn is solid on c6 it can be
reinforced with the queen if need be
the bishop can come out it's a more
flexible way of playing and it gives
black a lot of central control
yeah i apologize though sorry i forgot
to turn the light on
yeah we'll just continue continue like
this
my face is in clearer focus anyway so i
went for g5
and the idea is simply
the idea is simply to bring the knight
here and aim for play on the king side
at some point i want to play bishop e6
the problem now is this bomb
and after f4 h6 d3
all right we've got some combat on the
king side here this is pretty standard
stuff in the closed sicilian
and again by analogy it continues here
but once again i still like the idea of
c6 now
you know in retrospect i wish i had
played it
but i continued for my kingside play
how would you evaluate this position so
i think
i think especially now that i've
committed a bit too hard to this a bit
too much to this kingside
i would say white has some advantage for
sure right this bishop is actually a
very strong piece
and without c6 or d5 this is not a great
way to shut it down
and this is all easy to say in
retrospect because
during the game i would say in general i
overestimated my prospects on the king
side
right i was hoping for a direct play you
know maybe at some point play g4 and
push the h pawn or take and push the h
pawn and just try and tear a pipe tear
apart the king side pawn structures and
get a lot of play
so that's what i was hoping to do right
hindsight is 20 20. it doesn't work as
well as i was hoping
and that means black's just a little
uncomfortable here thanks to this bishop
right if these light-squared bishops
were gone i'd say black's completely
fine
maybe even a little better but now
black hasn't played c6 it's going to be
tougher to play in the future
and as we're going to see direct action
on the king side it's kind of nice to
keep in mind but white has too much
support
right this pawn is actually reinforced
five times
direct action is not strong enough so
white continues their development
all right queen b3 i play king h7 to get
out of the line of fire of this
of this queen
d2 very often this bishop goes here as
you might imagine this long diagonal is
very tempting
but in this case i would say he wanted
to keep reinforcement on f4
right to make sure that if i start
capturing you can always keep a piece
there
and this is where i would say i made a
big strategic mistake
this is again this is the kind of thing
that real understanding is so good for
and the kind of thing that's good to
take away from a game like this
right in this position i would say this
is kind of when i realized
there's not there's not a great way to
just push an attack through on the king
side
white has too much firepower now i was
hoping to do something direct
you know just open up the position maybe
take a bunch and push the h-pawn
another thing that occurred to me is g4
and h5 h4 but the problem is after h4 is
played
yeah white simply ignores it
and just ask okay what are you going to
do right you can't really put enough
pressure on g3
even if you go knight h5 it's still well
defended
and in the meantime maybe white takes
the a file light starts putting pressure
on the queen side
now there isn't a great way to break
through
so yeah i really like this right yeah as
you mentioned c6
to play bishop e6 i'd really like to do
that
i want to play c6 and bishop e6 but now
that this knight is not on e7
now this knight is not on e7 c6 is more
difficult
although i will say the move queen e8
now the move queen e8 to cover c6
just so i can play this i go to e8 and
not d7 because on d7 it would block the
bishop
queen e8 in order to play c6 is
absolutely an idea worth considering
even though it feels a little clumsy
right compared to already being able to
play c6 before
but this is absolutely a move to think
about
yeah and rook b8 right another move to
try and defend the spawn
it's possible right it enables this but
it's never a move you want to play right
this works on an open file
and you're moving it to a purely
defensive square
yeah so again playable but this is
this is the last resort kind of move
because the rook does not want to be
here you don't want to just give quite
this file
so at the end of the day i should
probably have played queen e8
either now or maybe i played g4 and then
queen e8
in order to keep this c6 idea in mind
and free up my queen side
in the game i was too direct i kind of
knew this wasn't
great for me it takes takes again i
couldn't play g4
but in the game i took
all right and after taking what's the
big downside
what's the big downside to this double
capture by black
what problem has black just established
with their position
well the pawn's hanging that's true but
it's just a recapture right when white
takes this pawn
white's just getting their pawn back so
it's not a matter of material
it has to do more with the other pawns
right so takes f4 is open to the knight
that's part
of it so white gets this and now these
pawns are
very clumsy this square is a great one
for white's pieces
this f5 pawn is isolated and kind of
weak and without an e or g pawn to
provide support
it's just very hard for white to do
anything right for black to do anything
sorry
white holds on to this f4 square
yeah three pawn islands right that's the
classic way to think of it black has
three pawn islands white has two black
spawn structure is weaker
black would absolutely love to have a
pawn on e5 right to control these sweet
squares
but that's not going to happen
and after knight takes
bishop takes yeah the dark so white
starts where bishop gets stronger
blacks does too but the problem is again
without pawn pressure there's just no
way to break into white's position
now i go knight h5 to target this square
but white just reinforces with an id2
and now the situation is very difficult
because again black would absolutely
love to take control of this f4 square
with a pawn
but there's no way to do that unless
white captures something and white's not
going to do that
so this pawn is just kind of in the way
and of course you know i haven't even
mentioned talking about all this
the problem of this b7 pawn still hasn't
been solved
so black should have really the key here
is to play more flexibly
rather than commit to this kind of
structure which isn't great i was hoping
for some kind of play
which this being a blitz game is very
much a blitz decision to make
but with white structure so solid that
kind of play is just unlikely to work
you just want you want to keep a solid
set of pawns
and go for this c6 idea
okay you could do the problem with rook
a7
so rook a7 so supporting the pawn is
very natural
maybe you even want to play b6 and you
could bring the bishop out
i do like those two things about rook a7
it covers this you keep you stay on the
a file
but concretely
there's a couple problems with it the
general problem is the rook here is
vulnerable
right the rook here can be targeted by
the bishop
b6 could be played but then you're
weakening some squares
yeah and correct manny when you play
rook a7
you also have to worry about b6
and just generally speaking
you can these pawns can be a very
serious weakness even if white doesn't
take right away
even bishop e3 here for example the rook
is kind of vulnerable on a7
it's another idea i would absolutely
consider but it also as you're kind of
seeing it has its downsides
again i'll just mention this one bishop
e3 if b6 is played you've got yet
another weak square might white might
try to jump into
so instead of that i just played rookie
8 trying to go to the open file
and white goes bishop f3
so here i kind of realized after knight
takes knight takes
yeah he got a new island yeah black has
a lot of islands here but
islands and chess are not as nice as
normal islands
i realized after this the light squares
are very weak
so i was forced to play knight f6
and kind of basically just completely
and forever concede the fight for this
f4 square
and at this point i mean the game is
still complicated black still has a lot
of play
but strategically black is in a lot of
trouble
i mean this being a blitz game there was
of course further drama there were some
tactics for both sides
i had a chance to recover but ultimately
in no small part due to just playing the
stage of the game
um more accurately he ended up winning
right and this
actually so congratulations to him this
won him i believe third place
in title tuesday
so it's a big lesson i would say in
preserving more flexibility because
right take getting rid of both of these
pawns or just kind of seeing
just how much stronger white's pieces
are i mean the
the most obvious example is the light
squared bishops
but even the dark squared bishops now
this bishop is kind of firing at nothing
and this bishop can put pressure on
black
so for me that's why this game i think
was a great game for review
a lot of learning experience and if you
haven't looked at the closed sicilian
before
you can kind of see just how useful it
provided here it
it proved to be here right how much the
same ideas applied the same queen side
play for white that black has
the same pawn push for black and the
same c6 when white might play c3 in the
close cecilia
yeah a couple very double-edged middle
games
and that's all i'll cover for today is
for time reasons
yeah next time perhaps we'll cover that
rizzevsky fisher game actually that is
some great material
so yeah sorry about the lighting
everyone i'll take care of that for next
time
and thank you all for watching i hope
you guys learned something useful from
this
but i trade his dragon for the rook on
a8 so by dragon i'm going to assume you
mean this bishop right like a dragon
bishop honestly probably not
i mean it would solve some problems but
the exchange is so much material
white can just go for more trades
the exchange is just too much to be down
unless you have some really active play
of your own
so yeah i hope that proved useful once
again thank you all for watching
and i hope to see you on a future
lecture
bye everyone